what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so getting into really the
conclusion of Batman the return of Bruce
Wayne again if those of you guys who
were just joining us this largely comes
after the events of Final Crisis when
Batman was sent to the very early days
of time and where he's kind of been
jumping forward through time for the
most part one of the big caveats with
this is that his memory was effectively
wiped now of course we'll actually find
out the motivation behind this and
there's actually a very particular
reason why this was done but the whole
ideology behind this is that it kind of
allows Grant Morrison the writer of this
story to kind of craft these
intertwining scenarios whereby we
basically end up learning Bruce Wayne
guarantees his own existence but in
regards to Dark Knights metal one of the
things that went on with that whole line
of stories is we basically learned there
was a bat got out there called Barbados
that existed in the dark multiverse and
the whole motivation was to basically
try to find a way to enter the positive
multiverse and then destroy it which
he's basically enter the positive
multiverse at the moment and then we're
kind of in the process of watching it be
destroyed because everybody seems to
have no chance to win but what the
return of Bruce Wayne does is it kind of
serves this purpose of being a bridging
gap between the events of Dark Knights
metal and what it is that led to the
introduction of Barbados and why it is
that his character is so significant to
the life and times of Bruce Wayne so
again when Bruce was thrown all the way
back into the early days that's when
Barbados first noticed him and that's
when Barbados came to the realization I
can use Bruce Wayne as a means to enter
the positive multiverse now in terms of
why it was Bruce Wayne it seems to be
more if he was just chosen plus I mean
he's Batman so it kind of makes sense
but the other idea is that it really was
kind of a bonding process in the sense
that in order for this gateway to kind
of be open Bruce had to be exposed to
various metals over the course of his
life and that's what Dark Knight's metal
does where Dark Knight's metal comes
along and says over the course of Bruce
Wayne's existence during this story he
was basically exposed to these different
metals through a series of events what
it does is it grabs this story and it
kind of throws information in that
wasn't here originally but in the
previous comic we had talked about how
he basically had been thrown into the
Age of pirates and that now he'd been
kind of sent to the age of cowboys more
or less but what did he keep in mind is
that what this initially does is it
picks up with a guy who's referred to as
Monsour savage now what did he keep in
mind is that monster Savage is actually
Vandal Savage and we had talked about
that and the first video we did on the
return of Bruce Wayne
Vandal Savage and this is how all that
Dark Knight's metal stuff kind of ties
together Vandal Savage was originally
just a guy who was basically exposed
a meteor I think it was which basically
granted him eternal youth now the same
thing was done to a guy named the
immortal man but when DC rebooted in
2011 writer Scott Snyder came along and
said actually what it was is it was a
substance called Dionysian and this
substance was basically you know exposed
to were consumed by Vandal Savage when
it was in his most pure form for the
sake of this video I assume that it all
kind of comes out a new 52 in the sense
that Vandal Savage is immortal because
he gained access to Dionysian he
consumed it and that's why he's able to
do the kind of things he does but he's
been a recurring theme he's played a
multitude of different roles over the
course of this life he's held for you
know however many thousands of years
since the very early days of man the
other half of this is that this also
deals with a handful of criminals who
are pursuing a box that has a Batman
insignia on it and of course there's
only really this woman who's here is the
one who can kind of decipher it a woman
by the name of Katherine and then of
course she's taken by the forces of
Vandal Savage and brought to his
location but what it does is it brings
in the character of Jonah Hex now of
course again we talked about this in the
last video so you're welcome to
reference that if you want to learn more
about his character but Jonah Hex was
always one of these weird scenarios in
the sense that he was a character it was
kind of like you know living in the Old
West and he was the other the world's
best bounty hunter and he was a fastest
gun in the West
had his own line of comics that really
pertain directly to him there were
stories that would see him kind of
thrown into the modern-day but more
often than not Jonah Hex is just kind of
associated with the Wild West
in the DC landscape but the fact that he
is the best bounty hunter is the reason
why he's been contracted by Vandal
Savage because having Jonah Hex here is
designed for the purpose of the fact
that after this woman Katherine had
basically lost her son everything that
she cared for she had basically reached
out and said you know God give me some
avenging angel that will take his
revenge on these men which is when
Batman had kind of shown up when Bruce
Wayne has shown up I remember he's
basically catapulted in time he doesn't
willingly choose to time travel
he doesn't willingly decide what place
he goes to he's just sent there but like
we would expect his detective skills are
somewhat subconscious and that means
that in every generation every era that
he appears in he basically becomes that
eras version of Batman he immediately
shows up in Gotham town I remember a lot
of this stuff takes place around the
city of Gotham for the most part it's
kind of inner twenty and part and parcel
to that landscape there's a few
instances where news beyond the realm of
Gotham but it largely focuses around
Gotham's vicinity at this point in time
Gotham's not fully fleshed out
great big huge town it's really more of
like a settlement than anything else we
also end up finding out that this
woman's basically being exposed to a
series of different pollution and
genetic drugs and different things like
that they're designed to kind of bring
out the nature of what's in this box
what it means and why it's so important
because that's the question everybody
wants as well as getting her to open it
up now again this is pretty intriguing
and it's kind of cool because the whole
idea of Jonah Hex being brought here we
end up finding out it's for the sole
purpose of protecting a Vandal Savage
because remember where Vandal Savage
could jump in and Vandal Savage could
fight Batman he relies in much the same
way as Batman on secrecy and guile and
people can't know that he's immortal if
they do they'll seek the means to
immortality just like he was able to
gain it himself and so the result is
keeping it all kind of him keeping his
true nature secret from a lot of
different people and so of course with
Batman attacking these various forces of
Vandal Savage being is really kind of
progress exactly as you would expect
them to you know they basically end up
really just kind of getting wrecks left
and right so on and so forth he end up
having Vandal Savage in a guy named
Thomas Wayne basically board a carriage
along with this woman and take off now
one thing I want you to keep in mind is
this character of Thomas Wayne because
he's not who he claims to be he is but
he isn't he's actually he's really more
well known by another name which is
Simon hurt and will actually find out a
little bit more about that here in a
second but it is a cool little bit a
little bit here just because of the fact
that this woman basically continues to
refuse to open the box not only that
she's a member of the Mia Gani and so
what this means is she's a descendant of
the bat tribe again keep in mind that
when it comes to Dark Knight's metal and
in the confines of this story when
Batman was thrown back all the way to
the earliest days of mankind in order to
keep his memory intact or at the very
least charterer try to maintain some
identity of who he is
he started scribbling drawings of you
know Wonder Woman's symbols and Superman
symbols at his own symbol so on and so
forth but he was wearing his cloak and
cowl and so because humanity was so
primitive
when he initially took off his cloak and
Carolee kind of threw it on a mantle
people saw that and they immediately
thought it was a symbol of like a
greater God or something along those
lines and that's where worship of the
bat tribe began to start now from there
it just kind of progressed over the
years the way that you think it would
legend gave way to myth and that's when
we start to get into the idea of the
character of Barbados because with the
particular story where this carriage
comes flying down the road you know
where they end up running into Alan
Wayne of course Alan Wayne is on the
process of you know ending his own life
but chooses not to ultimately comes into
contact with with
Catherine and the two of them basically
fall in love and they end up getting
married to one another so on and so
forth course Jonah Hex showing up at
Jonah Hex shooting Bruce Wayne Bruce
Wayne falling into the water and
basically waking up in the 1930s what it
did is it set in motion the nature of
Allen we remember what we know is that
Allen Wayne was basically the guy that
developed Gotham City he developed Wayne
Manor he's the one that led to like a
lot of these major buildings being
constructed but also keep in mind the
court of owls is currently in existence
and that's where dark nights metal
really begins to intertwine with the
nature of the return of Bruce Wayne
because the timeline really kind of
falls like this you basically ended up
having the formation of the positive
multiverse and the formation of the dark
multiverse and the whole idea was that
Barbados was just one of these beings
that existed out there that was designed
to basically destroy worlds that were
not supposed to exist when Bruce Wayne
was thrown back into the early days of
humanity Barbados took notice of Bruce
Wayne and so what he ended up doing was
saying there's a way for me to enter the
positive multiverse this of course came
after various instances where he tried
to enter and was ultimately defeated but
because of the fact that Bruce Wayne had
led to the formation of the bat rod what
this meant was that as this tribe began
to grow as it began to sort of progress
throughout the era of time where it was
predicated on Bruce Wayne Barbados kind
of co-opted it and basically said well
know what you guys have actually been
worshipping is meat and you guys need to
find a way to bring me into the positive
multiverse preying on the idea that a
lot of the later generations hundreds of
years down the line from the original
dawning of the bat tribe that people at
the time didn't really know where it
originated from they just knew whatever
legends were had handed down and it all
stemmed from a bat god and so again
that's why it was also a treating and
that's why it really works is because
this writers Scott Snyder granted what
Grant Morrison did and this story
reworking a little bit and then rolling
it over into dark knights metal and so
of course with Bruce Wayne arriving in
the 1930s it is kind of interesting
because again this also deals with the
modern day which is to say the Justice
League trying to figure out a way to
save Bruce Wayne and try to get him back
to the modern era now again that's
really more like an afterthought to the
story the bulk of everything that goes
on focuses almost exclusively on Bruce
Wayne but notice this Bruce Wayne's met
by the arrival of a woman named Marshall
amar now on the surface she doesn't
really seem to be that important or the
fact she'll actually be exceedingly
important but Marshall Lamar basically
shows up and says you just kind of
appeared you're just kind of there but
what I need is
one who basically has no name I need a
man with no real identity that can help
me solve a murder and when the question
is asked well whose murder needs to be
solved it's the murders of Thomas and
Martha Wayne what this means is that
Bruce Wayne is an adult at the same time
that he's a child and he's basically
trying to solve the murder of his own
parents what we end up having is a you
know Marshall Lamar present Bruce Wayne
with a kind of bat outfit so to speak
now the reason why this matters and the
reason why it's so important is because
this outfit stems from the fact that the
mother of Bruce Wayne Martha Wayne is
part of the Mia Gani if that arose the
father maybe he was maybe was Thomas
Wayne anyway one of Bruce Wayne's
parents were basically descended from
the bat trot and so what this meant was
that Bruce Wayne solidified his own
legacy essentially this basically leads
to him kind of dawning a 1930s outfit
very reminiscent to the old Batman
stories from a Detective Comics 27 and
you know from the 1940s you know late
nineteen thirties going into 1940s it is
kind of cool but this of course also
introduces a lot of information about
the parents of Bruce Wayne
there weren't readily available before
for the most part the lives of Thomas
and Martha Wayne when it came to DC
Comics was not really explored all that
often what this does is it comes along
and it basically offers this explanation
that Thomas Wayne was not nearly as
great as Bruce believed it was but he
was a guy who slept around a lot that
each heated on his wife different things
like that now this really seems to be
fed into the idea that the reputation of
the Wayne's is being destroyed as
opposed to this actually being legit but
notice this for Bruce Wayne himself a
lot of it just kind of gets ignored he
doesn't really worry about it too much
instead in his mind he knows who his
parents are and that's really the only
thing that matters is so of course
beginning this investigation the
question has to be asked if Thomas and
Martha Wayne were taken out and they had
to have been taken out by people who
were close to them now the reason why
this works is because of the fact that
remember where we know that Bruce Wayne
his parents were killed by Joe Chill
because it was in a dark alley it was a
mugging gone wrong Bruce does not put
this together because his memory has
been altered so for him he's tracking
down the murder of his parents you know
he's trying to figure all that out now
of course it rapidly comes to the idea
that his parents were killed in an alley
but more or less it's maintaining the
autonomy of the time because what you're
talking about is the possibility that if
Bruce Wayne for example were to go visit
his younger self it would revoke ibly
change the timeline they could
potentially alter his own future and so
what he has to do
this point with these little bits and
pieces of his memory begin to come back
and he knows the truth of the murder of
the top of Thomas and Martha Wayne
if he acts it could change the future so
he basically just kind of plays the role
that's assigned to him he does not tell
anybody who actually killed Thomas and
Martha Wayne
but of course visiting the Wayne Manor
grounds of Thomas and Martha Wayne of
course checking out the various tombs
and so on and so forth also does
consider to offer some insight into the
idea that Kathryn had basically died in
childbirth Allen Wayne went on to form
Gotham City different things like that
you know kind of allowed it to develop
so on and so forth and so what this ends
up doing is basically leading into this
investigation of sorts where Bruce kind
of takes on this mantle this outfit that
his father wore various get-togethers
galas things like that and it introduces
a group called the black glove now the
reason why I say this matters is because
they block glove is led by a man named
Simon hurt and Simon heard of course as
we just talked about went by the mantle
of Thomas Wayne
now Simon heard here - Batman 156 back
in 1963 and while his character has
played several roles over the course of
the Batman publication history in truth
I would say was Grant Morrison who
probably fleshed out a lot of his
history or really made a more intriguing
like what you're seeing right here this
idea that Simon heard had been around
for quite some time now he played a
pretty significant role in Batman's run
following the events really kind of
coinciding with this with like you know
Batman Robin going into like the future
of Batman following this story different
things like that the fact remains here
this whole ritual that's being conducted
by Simon hurt and the black glove is
done for the purpose of bringing
Barbados into the positive multiverse
now again that was not the original
intention because Marv Beto's didn't
exist at the time the story was written
in terms of how Scott Snyder's depicting
him instead grabbing this information
and rolling it over into dark knights
metal this is basically a part of the
bat tribe that broke off and eventually
became that Judas tribe also known as
the court of owls and so basically what
this means is that these guys are
serving the purpose of worshipping
Barbados and trying to bring Barbados
into the positive multiverse the only
issue is that Batman doesn't know about
it he has no idea what's really going on
here again we kind of have to take dark
knights metal and slap it on to this we
kind of have to offer that conjecture
just because of what we've seen the
story so far different things like that
again taking this story for what it is
Simon hurts just leading a group called
the black love and his idea is to bring
Barbados and is to take over the name of
Thomas Wayne and then just kinda
call it a day but with regards to Dark
Knight's metal again it feeds into the
idea that Barbados is trying to find a
way into the positive multiverse and
there are people that are trying to
bring him here so of course Marshall
Lamar was basically one of them that she
had set him on this path of eventually
running into the black glove and then
ultimately being used as a unwitting
member of their group to basically bring
him in and so what is happening here is
that where Bruce Wayne is able to
engineer his escape and he's sent
through time yet again where he travels
into the far distant future basically to
the end of all time itself the version
of Bruce Wayne from the end of all time
itself is transported to the present day
and what I mean by that here is we had
talked about in one of the previous
videos that by some form or fashion
Bruce Wayne was alive at the very end of
the universe and that version of himself
kind of a cyborg of sorts seemed to be a
villain and so when Superman and Green
Lantern and these you know the The Time
Traveller's more or less had come
together and try to find out what you
know try to locate Bruce at the end of
time or at least wait for him to arrive
there this evil version of ruse kind of
locked him in a prison and then jump
back to the present day what this does
is it tells us how he got there and what
we end up finding out is that where
Bruce Wayne was teleported to the very
very end of time that he immediately
came across these sort of beings more or
less that just kind of monitor time
itself they're like the timekeepers
something along those lines but they're
sort of like chronicling everything
that's happened over the course of the
universe now of course what this means
is that at this point in time the
universe is coming to an end is
basically at the final moments before
the universe goes kaput more or less
and so with Bruce Wayne arriving here
one is up happening is he remembers
everything that goes on and this is
where we start to get this great big
huge exposition on everything that's
happened so if you feel yourself being a
little confused don't worry we're gonna
fix that right now so essentially what
had happened with regards to this
timeline of events just in regards to
this story is that at the end of Final
Crisis Bruce Wayne was thrown to the
very very beginning of time and then
people saw his cloak and cowl and began
believing that you know there was a bat
god out there somewhere the bat tribe
formed Bruce Wayne kept getting thrown
forward through time and as he was
thrown forward through time his memories
began to restore it bit by bit and so by
the time he was thrown into this far
distant future he's basically remembered
everything the caveat to this is that
the monster that was chasing him the
hyper adapter had been sent back by dark
side for the purpose of eliminating
Bruce Wayne the issue with this is that
the hybrid
you're basically kind of intertwines
itself with Bruce's knowledge of who he
is and so as he began remember a bit by
bit the hyper adapter would chase after
him and so it's basically followed him
all the way to the very end of time in
order to ensure that he can travel back
to the present day and not have the
hyper adapter follow him he's had his
memories wiped yet again by these beings
which is the reason why he arrived
moments before Superman and all those
guys did and when they first encountered
him he was basically cybernetic and was
a villain because his memories had been
wiped and he didn't know who they were
and so again that's why all that really
seems to work is because in this
instance we end up having a Bruce Wayne
show up and of course he ends up in
countering Tim Drake along with the
other members of the Justice League in
the modern day now for the most part
because of the fact that he's a hybrid
of man and machine governed by a
singular purpose what this does is it
brings him into direct conflict with the
Justice League themselves who are trying
to find a way to defeat him just because
of the fact that he's basically
presenting himself as this extreme enemy
at the same time you also end up having
you know Superman and all those guys in
the future who are basically using
Batman's time capsule to transport
themselves you know back to the present
day so it's kind of one of these things
where all these bridges converged back
into a singular location now for his
part Tim Drake actually tries to talk
Batman down he tries to talk reason into
him and it's kind of cool because Bruce
Wayne starts to remember different
aspects of his past and his memories
sort of start to restore to a degree the
caveat to all this is that as those
memories start to restore then
ultimately the hyper adapter is going to
pursue him again as a result where Bruce
Wayne is able to take on various members
of the Justice League which culminates
in the arrival of like Superman in Green
Lantern and all these different guys
this expositions kind of offered yet
again in terms of what it all means and
how it all comes together so on and so
forth not only that this energy inside
of Bruce Wayne is basically stripped
away from him by Superman who quite
literally just kind of pulls it all off
and of course at that point is put into
a time stasis capsule which of course
leads to this energy kind of being sent
back to the very early days of man and
it's one of these things or Grant
Morrison plays on the idea that all of
this is doomed to repeat itself that all
of its going to happen again you know it
leads to the first battle between the
tribe of Vandal Savage and the bat tribe
which explains how it is a Vandal Savage
is able to find the bat tribe in the
first place so again it's all these
things that kind of feed in all of this
has happened before
and all of this has happened again what
it does is it allows Grant Morrison
basically solidify the story and
essentially say that this is doomed to
happen but what is up taking place here
is that following the events of Bruce
basically having this source of energy
kind of cast off of him he gets this
sort of image you know where he's
basically here where his lifeforce is
kind of stopped more or less his heart
is kind of stopped by the Justice League
he ends up getting this image of like
Darkseid at Metron things like that they
try to pull him in two different
directions
the idea of Darkseid is embrace anti
life energy so that I can be reborn
basically it's Darkseid trying to bring
himself back simultaneously it's Metron
saying you can't do that you have to
embrace the nature of what it really
means to be Batman and accept the truth
of Batman and what this does is it
establishes the idea that Batman's never
alone that's effectively the nature of
what Grant Morrison was doing with this
whole story it was taking the nature of
Bruce Wayne taking the nature of the
anti-life equation the domination of
people's will to live and kind of
rolling it all together into a nice
package and reworking Bruce Wayne so
that were traditional stories a
conventional thought would always give
way to this idea that Bruce Wayne is a
guy who believes that he'll always be
alone Grant Morrison comes along and
says that's not true in fact Bruce Wayne
always needs people he needs the Justice
League he needs the Robins he needs
other Batman so what this does is it
lays the groundwork for the post return
of Bruce Wayne line of stories from
Grant Morrison which go on to basically
offer this thing called Batman
Incorporated and this is quite literally
a story which is far less complicated
than this where Bruce Wayne travels
around the world and starts forming an
international Batman team basically all
these different Batman from all these
different parts of the world now of
course that all goes into new 52 and it
goes into really what's happening right
now with regards to like Batman comics
and Detective Comics as part of DC
rebirth one of these really weird
stories this is one of those stories
where you're kind of best reading it and
sort of digesting it as best you can
because again we can't run over every
single nook and cranny in the story but
if you guys are new here to come this
explain make sure you guys have the sub
button to become part of the Rob core if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and yeah I will catch
you all later please
[Music]